it's amusing the anime with all its
supernatural powers and weapons often
comes down to just one thing
want to create a decisive moment in a
fight or a confrontation nothing beats
the good old right fist that's right
we're taking a good look at some of the
best punches delivered in anime some
might be simple but of course our main
highlight will be planet shattering
punches that defy the laws of physics or
once filled with so much emotion the
viewers can't help but get caught up in
the moment I won't keep you waiting so
let's begin
[Music]
Jonathan Joestar versus do is a storied
rivalry for people in the Jojo fandom is
it any surprise that one of the duo's
most important confrontations comes down
to one punch to end it all if anything
this is the fight to showcase how badass
Jonathan is armed with just his bare
fists and his resolve he brings his
everything in that one punch against an
ever powerful nemesis in do
despite Gio's a supernatural strength he
proves no match against Jonathan's final
punch which wrecked him to kingdom come
talk about overkill deal gets
disintegrated right there unfortunately
for Josiah that's not the end of do as
he comes back to haunt Joestar and his
family multiple times to me Jonathan
should have gone for the head
[Music]
that's one big way to end a series final
fight for all the special magic and
creative powers that fairy tale
introduced to its final arc the climax
comes down to the classic fairy tale way
Natsu powered up by the almighty
friendship with everyone cheering
delivers a huge rainbow colored fire
dragon punch to acne Logie apparel year
no one survives that especially if
you're a villain in fairy tale back with
the cool dragon force theme Natsu
finishes the final battle in the only
way he can for me the cool moment here
is acne logia realizing that he can't
block the attack because of the injuries
he sustained in the fight against igneel
even in death the fire dragon still
finds a way to lead his son to victory
attack on titan is a series where the
power of friendship doesn't get it done
all the time nonetheless it provides us
with the next punch on the list courtesy
of Aaron in the seventh episode the
punch is quick and easy and you can feel
the real impact of it connecting that's
one critical hit the fans won't be
forgetting anytime soon with one back
hand boom that head went flying crashing
all the way into a building that's one
way to build up and showcase Aaron's
newfound power as a Titan I mean we've
got to keep him looking strong until we
can put him toe-to-toe with the real big
guns right good luck trying that stunt
on Annie
[Music]
Naruto the last has some cool and
memorable moments but for me one of the
highlights is this punch in his battle
against an eerie Naruto channel's his
tailed beasts mode chakra out of his
hand
resulting in one super punch clutching
onto the scrap of Hinata's cloak
Naruto delivers a punch that shakes the
field creating craters in its wake and
sending ternary flying the animation
team went all the way in presenting the
power behind the punch I'm sure I'm not
the only one who felt the pound when
Naruto Alisha's his all to enter nari
really noticeable is the shock on
Tania's face did Naruto just finish him
off in one punch unbelievable is that
you Saitama
get out you know that
how can we go through a top 10 list of
punches without going through a boxing
match in this entry we look at the
intense battle between komagawa and
Anderson the to wage war inside the ring
and by the end the fight came down to
one headshot nope instead of getting the
high punch he expected Anderson is
surprised to see his opponent decided to
go for a body blow coming from beneath
Kamogawa charges up a rib shattering
punch and knocks his opponent out with
one powerful blow the camera really
makes you feel the impact of the punch
and the acting in the scene is just
superb now that's a knockout blow if
I've ever seen one
my tsunami one on day if there's a
cardinal rule in anime its to never
anger the Shonan protagonist especially
one who feels as passionate about others
as Luffy seeing hard she gets shot was
enough to send Luffy over the edge
without a second thought he swings at
chalice and sends him flying across the
room we've seen Luffy punch a lot of
people but this is one of the more
impulse driven and emotional ones in the
series the reactions of the characters
says it all everyone's left speechless
as they stare at the destruction Luffy
punched a celestial dragon without
hesitation or care for the consequences
that would follow through the Navy
Admirals that come right who cares about
the Marines and what they think
classic monkey dee Luffy dragon would be
so proud of his son
[Music]
coming a status quo changing revelation
and character progression gone proceeds
to destroy pizza in what many consider
to be one of the peak moments of hunter
hunter the knowledge of gone being taken
over by his newfound nihilism the
animation and acting all come together
to produce a masterpiece of a scene the
punch GaN delivers simply puts the
exclamation mark on the build-up it says
something when God's picture in this
scene becomes one of the most commonly
used photos to represent the top moments
of Hunter Hunter 2011 with something as
big and as awesome as that only a
finishing punch like the one that
Gaughan delivered would be enough to put
a satisfying conclusion to this battle
why hero academia fans have long been
waiting for this and the anime more than
delivered a recent episode of my hero
academia C's midoriya unleashed 100% one
for all against overhaul with a villain
capable of transmutation and
transformation is sheer force gonna be
enough turns out all you need to do is
hit the other guy hard enough and enough
times but that doesn't make the scene
any less epic midoriya attacks overhaul
with a barrage of punches breaking
through all the protection the villain
has midoriya gets his signature intense
Shonen hero shock before blasting
overhaul from the sky with one serious
punch capping everything off with a bang
serious punch after a barrage of punches
reminds me of someone else we know back
to the topic and I'd like to say that
for such an overpowered villain overhaul
met his match here
the Gerudo insane feats by Japanese
people with powers when's the last time
you saw someone part to see with a punch
never right in contrast to his usual
portrayal as a crafty monkey Sengoku
Basara z-- hideo she's a gorilla of a
man ruthless and powerful his win-loss
record against heroes is a testament to
his power but none can match his Sea
parting punch in terms of how all
inspiring it is such a display of power
is something the only anime can do I
wouldn't be surprised if his opponents
heads explode from one of those punches
Hideo she's pretty much a God in human
form a God among mortals and I'm not
exaggerating you've got to see this clip
to believe it
[Music]
and at the top of it all is you guessed
it Saitama
people don't need much convincing to
come to terms with how overpowered
Saitama is but just to give an example
we have his performance against Boris to
show all villains are said to fought
against Saitama in one hit and after
watching this scene it's not hard to
know why boss himself got a front row
seat to witness the destruction a
serious Saitama can bring after an
intense battle that spans across space
and features the alien leader
regenerating through saitama's punches
barash decides that it's time to end it
all releasing his trump card collapsing
star roaring cannon he looks to kill
Saitama and eradicate the planet it's
this over-the-top craziness that makes
one punch man such as satisfying an
entertaining watch and for me there's no
better showcase of that than the serious
punch again for us
that just about sums it up for our top
10 anime punches which one is your
favorite despite it not being at the
very top of the list in terms of being a
spectacle I mean I personally find
myself having a soft spot for Kamogawa
punch I really felt that when I first
saw it how about you as usual like and
subscribe if you enjoyed this content
and the Bell buttons there so you can
easily get first-hand access to the
latest updates and videos see you in the
next video
[Music]